i've talked before about how my favorite
application of quantum computers is
quantum simulation
so i thought i'd make a video about it
to explain what it is why i'm so hyped
for it
and also later on in the video i'm going
to be running my very own quantum
simulation on an ibm quantum computer
i'm going to be using a software
development kit called kisskit who are
in fact sponsoring this video
and what's really cool is this is
available to anyone for free to run
software
on a quantum computer so more on that
later
but first of all why am i so excited
about quantum simulation
now quantum simulation is a really
promising route to
discover the technologies of the future
by helping us investigate or discover
new materials with new physical
properties
now the area of physics that's involved
with studying the physical properties of
solids and liquids
is called condensed matter physics and
it's actually what i did my phd in
but it's interesting not many people
have heard of condensed matter physics
before
despite the fact that it's a huge area
of research and it's kind of
invented the modern world so a big
success story of condensed matter
physics was
being able to describe and understand
the band structure
so how semiconductors conduct
electricity
that led to a huge amount of
technologies like computers the internet
and also
it's kind of the digital revolution
digital cameras
the screen you're watching this on and
we call this
the digital age and that's because the
history of humanity
a big part of our story is our ability
to
find and harness materials and use their
physical properties to invent new
technology
so what is a material a material is just
a certain configuration
of atoms and there could be
configurations of atoms out there with
novel physical properties
either their physical properties like
their strength or how
they interact with light or their
magnetic properties or their electronic
properties
and so we want to try and search for
novel
materials because we we probably haven't
found them all
yet so let me give you a concrete
example
superconductivity superconductivity is a
bizarre feature of certain materials
for example if you take a wire of
aluminium and you cool it down
to a very low temperature just 1.75
kelvin it will start to superconduct
which means that
electrical current can flow through it
with zero resistance literally zero
resistance
so you could set up an eddy current a
circulating current in a wire of
aluminium
that would just keep looping literally
forever
as long as you keep it cold now we
already use this technology
for superconducting magnets in mri
scanners or in particle accelerators
but the keeping them cold part is a
total bummer because
that's a really hard thing to do and so
for a long time people have been
searching for some material that
superconducts at room temperature
that would mean that we could build say
computers that
wouldn't generate any heat at all and
means we could potentially make them
a lot more compact way more energy
efficient and also a lot quieter
in fact earlier this year they
discovered the very first room
temperature
superconductor material called
carbonaceous
sulfur hydride which superconducts at 15
celsius or 59 fahrenheit
but only if you squeeze it really hard
between diamond anvils to 75
the pressure of the center of the earth
so still not quite practical
but the point is there could be a
material out there that super conducts
at room temperature and
room pressure we just haven't discovered
it yet
and because we don't have a theory of
high temperature superconductivity
searching for that material is currently
a bit like
alchemy you just try different
combinations of different materials
grind them up squeeze them together and
see what their properties are
but with a quantum simulator potentially
you could
search through all of those different
combinations
a lot quicker and measure their physical
properties in the simulator
so the big picture is we've got the
entire periodic table
at our disposal and different
combinations of the elements will
produce materials with different
physical properties
but the number of combinations is huge
essentially
infinite but that's just one aspect
another aspect is what happens when we
bring those materials together
and that's essentially chemistry and now
we're faced with another infinite set of
combinations
not just the materials but then also the
combinations of different materials
interacting with other materials
but we can use quantum simulation to
simulate those interactions as well
so here's an example from chemistry
making fertilizer for agriculture is
currently a very energy
intensive process and as a consequence
it's got a very high carbon footprint
now if we could somehow improve the
catalyst we use to convert molecular
nitrogen into a form that plants can use
we could reduce the energy expenditure
of this process and actually bacteria
somehow do this way more efficiently
than our current processes do
this is the catalyst that bacteria use
and we'd really love to understand
the quantum physics of this chemical
reaction but
our current best techniques running on
conventional computers
struggle with this and so it'll be
brilliant to be able to simulate this on
a quantum computer
in fact researchers at microsoft
calculated that you could simulate this
if you had 200 perfect qubits which
practically means you'd need about 200
000
physical qubits depending on how good
the qubits are
so that gives us an idea of how many
qubits you'd need to have
in order to solve a really valuable
problem
so i've talked a lot about the potential
of quantum simulation
in the future but where do we stand
right now in the world today
well a big part of this is in the
development of quantum computers several
different companies are developing
quantum computers around the world
i also mentioned qubits qubits are the
fundamental unit of computation in a
quantum computer
and in general all these people are
trying to increase the number of qubits
in their systems
but also try and increase the quality of
those qubits to drive down the error
rates of those qubits when they're doing
calculations
now as of recording this video google
have got a quantum computer with 72
qubits in it
and ibm have got another one with 65
qubits in it
but apart from quantum computers there's
other techniques as well for quantum
simulation like trapped ion systems
or ultracold atoms trapped in optical
lattices
and there's a bunch of other techniques
too
but wait what's stopping us from
simulating quantum systems on a
conventional computer
can't we just do that well we do already
the trouble is it gets exponentially
more difficult the more quantum
particles that are involved which means
that theoretically
a quantum simulator will be
exponentially faster
at solving the laws of quantum physics
than a classical computer
but but in practice we're actually very
good at fudging things using
conventional computers
and the exponential only applies if
we're solving the laws of quantum
physics
precisely and so if you're willing to
accept a little
in a bit of inaccuracy you can use some
sneaky tricks
otherwise known as statistical methods
to give you pretty good answers pretty
quickly
these techniques include monte carlo
simulations or density functional theory
which can approximately solve the laws
of quantum physics for
thousands if not millions of atoms
depending on the accuracy that you need
and these have actually been
successfully used to develop new
materials for things like batteries
so in the future the sensible approach
for quantum simulators
as they develop and mature is to use
them alongside
these classical techniques in a kind of
hybrid approach a bit like how we
already use cpus and gpus in our in our
normal
computers the real potential for quantum
simulators
is to solve those problems where the
approximate techniques
fail this would be in problems where
even a small
error in calculating the energy levels
of a molecule or an atom leads to
big errors in say the rate of a chemical
reaction or
in superconductors where the whole
behavior of the material depends
very strongly on the precise interaction
between
an electron and an atom so in general
for chemistry simulations you need
one cubit for each electron orbital so
to perfectly simulate hydrogen you'd
need 56 qubits
which google did in 2016. but in
practice
that's an upper limit you can actually
use encodings that decrease that number
in 2017 ibm simulated lithium hydride
and also beryllium hydride
and in 2019 ion q managed to simulate
water using a trapped ion system
okay so now time to run an actual
quantum simulation
so i'm currently connected to a quantum
computer
ibm and in this simulation what i'm
trying to do is
find the natural configuration of a
lithium hydride
molecule so the distance between the
lithium atom and hydrogen atom in that
molecule
so the lowest energy state of the atom
so here i'm plotting the results the
orange points are from the quantum
simulation
compared to the exact solution and it's
got the right answer the lowest energy
is the correct distance between the
atoms
at 1.5 angstroms so this is a
pretty simple simulation but
the fact that i'm running it on an
actual quantum computer is pretty cool
but what's really cool about this is
that it's open to the public so
any of you could write some code and
access ibm's quantum computers
as well which i think is amazing um this
is using
a software library called kisskit and i
learned how to use it using kisskit's
youtube channel which i've got a bunch
of really good tutorials on
many different aspects not just quantum
simulation but some famous quantum
algorithms like
shaw's algorithm grover's algorithm and
some quantum machine learning stuff
and i think this is cool because a bunch
of people have asked me
over the years like how to get into
quantum computing or how to learn
quantum physics
and i think this is a really good way of
going about it because it gives you a
motivation to learn about those
features of quantum physics like
superposition and entanglement
by actually getting in and getting your
hands dirty so
i've linked to the youtube channel in
the description below so make sure you
go check that out and you can learn
also how to run a quantum simulation
from your kitchen
so a question is how long is it going to
be until there's a quantum computer
that's good enough to actually solve
some of these real world problems
well here are the best universal quantum
computers that exist
in the world today now ibm have released
their roadmap for the next few years and
what they hope to
produce over a thousand qubits in a
system by 2023
and both google and ibm have said that
they want to produce a system with over
a million qubits by 2030
so over the next 10 years that's a huge
amount of development
and by then that's likely that they'll
be in a realm where they can actually
solve some problems that are useful that
you can't solve on
on classical computers now like i said
before just the qubit count is only one
side of the equation also improving the
quality of the qubits
is very very important for them to work
at scale
but there are some skeptics and there
are some significant problems that still
need to be overcome
for example routing the wiring to be
able to address
a million qubits is currently a problem
no one knows how to solve you can't
physically fit a million
microwave lines down into their dilution
refrigerators
so that's a problem that they need to
solve these also assume that we can
implement quantum
error correction at scale which is
something that we
works in theory but we haven't actually
done in practice and there's some
uncertainty about how effective
it will be so there are still some open
questions and you'll find skeptics out
there but
personally i feel like we've seen enough
track record over the last few years to
be
to be optimistic and of course we don't
know how difficult it will be to scale
up these systems but
there's only one way to find out which
is to actually throw some resources at
them
and try and build them and we know that
if we can
make large-scale quantum computers there
are some real practical real world
problems that
they'll help to solve so i think it's
worth the investment
and i'm very excited to see what happens
over the next 10 years
all right well that's all i wanted to
say about quantum simulation
i hope you enjoyed the video hope you
have a good holidays
i'll be taking a little bit of a break
to fill up my brain with
with with new science facts
and i'll be back in the new year with
some more videos so i'll see you then
[Music]
so
[Music]
you